most people don't know how to set a
formal table I don't know why you would
need to know how to set a formal table
but in case you were wondering
here's how to set a proper formal table
first you start with a charger plate a
charter plate is basically a really big
plate that you're not allowed to eat off
of instead you use it as a placeholder
for your dinner plate your dinner plate
is then accompanied by the salad plate
because apparently your salad is too
good to be on the same plate as the rest
of your dinner that's right we have
three different plates for no particular
reason now you have a dinner fork and
dinner knife on either side of your
stack of plates just make sure to keep
Forks on the left and don't forget this
is separate from your salad fork and
soup spoon because again it's incredibly
important that your salad have its own
dedicated setup not to mention this
adorable little tea spoon because god
forbid you stir your tea with the spoon
that you already have over here on the
left you have yet another plate and
butter knife for your bread yes indeed
to be proper you need to give your bread
its own knife and plate for plates on
the table and a stack of civil ware
let's move on to glassware to be proper
you need a water glass a wine glass and
a champagne flute
if that's not a waste of space I don't
know what is if you haven't dessert this
evening you'll need yet another teeny
tiny pair of fork and spoon to sit just
above your whole setup and to top it all
off you can set a poorly folded napkin
on top of the whole shebang and voila
you ready to eat the most pretentious
meal of your life this is Sookie
unnecessary